I will get there for now I grind it will
pay off in what I build or who I become
I hit my goal or I grow either way I win
welcome to the one of zero Show episode
2 advice for achieving your goals faster
than everyone else I'll be taking
questions from the audience
live who what's up everyone happy uh
Happy Wednesday in whatever time zone
you're in thank you for joining us on
the one of zero show so this is
something that
backed by popular demand uh we tried it
uh a few weeks ago you guys liked it so
uh we are doing it again we repeating
successful actions so as long as you
guys keep liking it we will keep doing
it today's theme is around uh goal
setting um but I'll be super transparent
with you I uh I was talking to a family
member who's probably going to die in
the next you know certain period of time
um and it so you're definitely going to
get me in a little bit of a a mood um
around that so I said that as a little
bit of a preface uh for our for our
conversations today um so when I when I
give you responses take them the way I
mean them uh which is hopefully the good
way all right so let's uh let's rock and
roll Alex what's up man Joe what's up
man how's it going dude doing fantastic
hey sorry to hear about your family
member by the way brother that's very
unfortunate we we all die that's right
that's right and I really appreciate
everything you do for the community
between your books and your free content
man you're the man you've helped me
change my life dramatically dude you're
like a god so you know I want to get
that out of the way I got the
acquisition hat is the lead book just
show you big gu big big fan of your work
man well thanks what can I help you with
man so uh I had a question about setting
really large goals because obviously
you've sat and had a ton of large goals
and throughout your entrepreneur journey
and you know whether that be uh annual
revenue for a business weight loss
personal savings Etc things with uh a
definite ending to it how would you
would you say it's better to set a time
frame for these large goals and have a
shoot for the star land of the moons
mentality and not hit it or have a time
frame that you know you're going to hit
it in and is it easier when you have
these large goals to chunk them into the
smaller goals along the way so that way
you feel like you're progressing
throughout throughout the Journey of the
larger goal
yeah um it's a good question and I'm
glad we're starting off with this one um
I see both of the examples that you gave
as kind of extremes that don't
necessarily need to exist um because
both of theirs are based on outcome
based expectations whether it's short or
long um and The more I've been doing
this the more I make my goals around
things that are 100% controllable and so
the outcome on the short term or the
outcome on the long term neither of
those are controllable but the activity
that I can commit to are controllable
and those activities I can measure
progress against them even on percentage
of days that I do the activities I said
I would do and so it's like somebody who
says they want to lose weight and it's
much better to say like well why don't
you just go to the gym um and so like
actually there's a an employee who's
just starting to go to the gym um and he
was like what program should I follow
and I was like your program is binary is
that did you go to the gym I was like
that's youram yeah and the first month I
want to just see how how many days you
do it and then next month we'll try and
increase that number and then once you
can do it all the days that you're
supposed to be going then we can start
adding things but until then I don't
think there's any point in anyone
putting any effort into what your
programming is because you can't stick
with [__] right and so um to your the
second half of what you said which is
like do you break things down into like
very very minute level I pretty much
only do that because I I basically say
okay this is what would be cool but if
it doesn't happen or it does is
relatively irrelevant because I think
that if I do these things that'll happen
but the only thing I can control is
doing these things and then what happens
is if I if I if I hit a 100% of my doing
these things and then the goal doesn't
happen I will still feel like I
accomplished what I said I was going to
do and so um that built my own
confidence in terms of my sticking with
my word because that's the that's like
one of the few things I care a lot about
is that if I say I'm going to do it I'll
do it and so then what you can then do
is Alter your hypothesis around goal
setting so this is going to be for
everybody so this isn't Just For You Joe
um I probably should have done this at
the at the at the Forefront of how we
set goals but at acis.com we have a very
simple process for setting goals number
one is we say what problem are we
solving and that problem should chunk up
to one of three things either we're
going to this if we solve this problem
it's preventing us from getting more
customers so if we solve it we'll get
more
customers it's going to we're not making
enough money per customer so if we solve
it we'll make more money per customer
and number three is that it's going to
decrease our risk of either of the first
two happening over the long term which
increases Enterprise Value right so if
you think about the value of a company
overall it's number of customers times
LTV or lifetime value and how long that
will happen and How likely that will
continue to happen in the long run and
so all bucket so that
help if they're like hey I think we
should make this a goal I'd be like well
how's it going to do one of these three
things and if they can't explain it then
it's probably not worth doing which many
things could improve a business but we
have limited resources and the job of
the CEO is to allocate money and effort
and so if we're the allocator of those
resources we have to make sure it's
going to the bucket's going to get us
the highest return so number one column
is does it get us more customers does it
make them worth more uh or is it
decreasing the risk that uh those things
are going to stop happening in the
future that's column one column two is
what's my hypothesis so I believe that
if we do this F if we do X Y will happen
right that's so it's just a hypothesis
statement because we we make these goals
but there's always an underlying
assumption that we think something's
going to happen if we do this I think if
I double the amount of videos I put out
I'm going to get more clicks to my
website that's the hypothesis now the
goal that we're trying to solve is get
more customers my hypothesis if I double
my number of videos that I make I'll get
more customers or get more clicks to my
site cool so then column three and
column four is what is X and what is y
right which is what is the thing I'm
going to do and what do I going to
happen and so that's the first part of
the goal setting that's all we do what
problem are we solving What's the
hypothesis what's the X which is the
input what's the Y which is the output
that's all we do we do with every single
company that's what we do every quarter
that's we do every every annual planning
that's what we do after the quarter or
the time period's over we then have two
more columns to say did we do X did we
actually double our number of videos and
then did why happen because you can also
set you can double your number of videos
but then you find out that your quality
drops and so you actually didn't get the
number of clicks that you thought to
your site so you had a hypothesis but it
was wrong and we're like okay so we need
to amend our hypothesis we have to
double our number of videos while also
making sure that we script them and have
ideas that are just as good as they were
before so then we have to solve that
problem right but that is the process
that we that we tackle all of our goals
and I have I have spent less and less
time thinking huge huge amounts in the
future I mean exciting stuff sure if
you're Vision casting for the team to
say like this is the big problem we're
going after but in terms of the doing
this of the business everything's down
to like what are the activities what are
we committing to and then the outcomes
take care of themselves and as far as
I'm concerned if the entire team did
everything they said they were going to
do and we didn't achieve any of those
quote outcomes that doesn't matter to me
at
all wow yeah there was a lot unack there
uh
very very insightful stuff I love when
you go on like the Riff uh I'll
definitely have to play that one back
and take notes man that was
really just break down the activities
just break down like you have so what's
the goal that you have right now what
whatting so that kind of goes into my
second question so there's a big goal
okay um early on in your career you know
because I follow I know your story uh
you know you had one of your mentors
switch you from doing the local gyms
into consultancy license model with gym
launch so you know my main goal for this
year and going forward is and it's just
I'm kind of in Crossroads and what
exactly I should do because I really
want to help as many people as possible
that is my like big term goal and I
think my biggest uh you know leverage
activity that I could do to help as many
people as possible is to do a similar
model to yours to help struggling
landscape owners get from zero to1
million do in gross revenue with you
know 20 30% margins um but what advice
would you give to me if you were in my
shoes while still trying to grow my
landscape business and switch to this
business model and start a you know
consult uh model yeah so right now what
you have is a strategic question um
rather than really a goal like you have
a directional question that you need to
make a decision about within the
business and so most brick and mortar
business owners kind of have three three
potential paths that they can expand
right so one is just private ownership
you just continue to own and open more
and more locations all right that's
number one number two um is kind of in
between there is you kind of have a
franchise uh franchise model right you
have you test you know you have one to
five locations of your own that you own
at corporate and then you franchise the
model out you can license model out
whatever um the the furthest from that
is what I would consider just more of an
education based business which is which
is sounds like what you were kind of
referencing
um at at scale all three of those help
lots of people so I wouldn't say that
one way helps more than another and even
the advice that I got at that time I
don't know if I would have given me that
advice that's just the advice that I got
because if I had gone back in time I
might have 200 gems right now and IID
probably be just as rich as I am now
so you know what I mean like it winners
will
win and problem I'll say this is that
the problem with starting over because
that's what this is is that when you
start into this new thing you're
starting at zero because you're now
competing in a brand new landscape
you're going from B to C to B2B you have
to understand National advertising
versus local
it's a it's a totally different game
right um
and it's tough to give you like what is
the right path because you can win at
all three but I would say that I
wouldn't downplay the amount of people
that you help with your current business
because how many employees do you employ
right now who now like enjoy their jobs
because you you know have a good setup
for them and you encourage them and you
know you give them career advancement
and how many people get time back in
their lives because you take care of
their landscaping for you so they can do
other things they can be with their kids
be with their families whatever it is
right so I think I think um it's a
short-term long-term thing right now
this feels shiny and new to like pursue
this other thing because it's money
that's right here but um I had a I had a
a business owner who had a single
location who approached me four four-ish
years ago uh and he was a similar
position as you and I advised him
against doing um what you were kind of
outlining uh and the main reason was I
just said well how much does it cost to
open a new location and he was like I
don't know like 40 or 50 Grand and I was
like okay well how much do they make
he's like I don't know 300 400,000 in
profit and I was like okay well we
should just run that play as much as
humanly possible and forget about the
whole like licensing thing and now that
company is a a behemoth is a nine figure
business now four years later uh with
hundreds of employees that help
thousands of families tens of thousands
of families every single year and so I
think that you can think just as big as
you want in any of these vehicles and
you currently already have paid down the
ignorance tax of what you're currently
doing like you're just getting to the
point where you're starting to make
money and doing a good job with it when
it gets boring is usually when you need
to go harder right like when it gets so
easy right that you're like I could do
this with my eyes closed when you can do
it with your eyes closed that's when you
10x it right rather than say okay now
this is easy I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
hit myself in the [__] head and try
and try to learn something new because
I'm an entreprene and I just like like
making my life hard but boring is where
you get rich like location location you
know how many locations you got now um
so it's just one centralized crew of
four four full-time guys and then one
project manager and it just one of the
biggest bottom necks with it is just it
takes a lot of capital and skilled labor
to do you know what I do which is kind
of like you know expert landscape design
with insulation landscape you know just
a little bit more Niche landscaping area
without going too much into detail so I
just think it' be harder to scale
compared to giving the framework that I
used over the last four years of all
that information similar what you did
with gyms to other business owners that
are struggling because there's tons of
guys in the business that are under a
million per year that they're just
struggling and I really think i' like to
help those guys because I've helped
people in my you know in my area just
giving them tips and they're like man
this tip really helped and you know like
dou with my leads you know all this
things so I have the information it's
just that's what I'm really really
struggling with you know it's a
short-term long-term thing man like it's
ABS so I'll say this you gotta pick
where you want the difficulty in terms
of scaling right like the the the doing
the the tips and tricks and selling
those and whatnot very easy to make
quick money very hard to make huge
money the the difficulties that you have
right now the good news is that once you
overcome those difficulties you then can
scale and whatever whatever monsters you
have to slay onest and building uh
Coastal creation right to uh something
really big
the person you is going have to slay the
same dragon and if it's really easy for
you to just do this other thing it's
really easy for someone else to do it
too and so a lot of people see hardship
and scaling as some somehow a bad thing
but they're just also called Moes or
competitive barriers that other people
would have to overcome and so I'll just
rewind this to like if you want to make
a shitload of money in terms of build
huge Enterprise Value the thing and like
ultimately sell a business then you want
to go private ownership or you want to
go a franchise route if you want to just
make income
then by all means you can sell
information it has high margins and you
can do it that way but it's very
difficult to make it recurring um it's
very difficult to turn that into an
Enterprise it's very easy to make it
into a high income generating thing but
you will give yourself a job that pays
well most likely and that's what most
people who are in that space
have gotcha okay well yeah I know
there's like seven people behind me
trying to ask for questions so I'll uh
you so don't worry there's a hundred
other people who had the same question
as you who that that served so you're
good man thanks so much Jo I appreciate
it I appreciate you Alex thanks man
100% Alex how's it going good man what's
up I'm great thanks man I really
appreciate that you take the time to
answer my question um I speak of goals
not in terms of achieving specific
things like making x amount of dollars
but more of a goal for the business life
you know uh imagine you don't really
know what you want to do but maybe you
know what you don't want to do sure how
to set the riot under quotes goals is it
simply the opposite of what you don't
want I think it's a wonderful way to
start because if you uh I mean Charlie
Monger said all I wish I could do is
know where I'm going to die and just
never go there obviously you know rest
in peace to Charly but um I think it's
it's a wonderful exercise because
sometimes trying to figure out what you
want is really really hard but a lot of
people know really clearly what they
don't want and you can go you can
approach the process through elimination
and then once you eliminate everything
what's left over you can again what are
all the things I don't like about what's
left over and you eliminate more until
eventually you're left with things that
you're like you know this isn't bad and
then you look up you know two years from
now and you're like you know what I kind
of like my life um and from a business
life perspective uh just for me
personally that that's very much the
path that I followed um I looked back at
the last few years of my life and was
like okay what were the good days what
were the bad days I said what were the
common things that happen on my bad days
okay how do I not do that stuff and then
what were the common things that
happened on my good days well how do I
do more of that and over the last few
years I've just try to engineer my days
to just be as many of the good things in
a row as I can um I had a mentor way
back or like 10 12 years ago um and I
had had a particularly good weekend and
I went into work and uh I said yeah I
said this great weekend and she said
something really insightful and she's
like I'm pretty sure the key to
happiness is stringing as many days in a
row like that as you can and it was just
such a simple operationalized way of
just seeing um living a more enjoyable
life um that I took that to heart and so
that's kind of how I've approached it
and I you know for a very long time kind
of lived by the whole [__] happiness
Mantra uh which is like I just I don't
care I'm going to do things and I'm
going to be useful to society um
independent of whether I enjoy it or not
but um in my lack of pursuit of it um a
few years ago I was on a podcast and
somebody asked me like are you happy and
I thought to myself I was like you know
what I used to introduce myself as like
hey I'm not the happiness guy like don't
listen to me for that but I can help you
make more money um but I enjoy my life a
lot now um which is you know almost a
surprise to me as it might be anybody
else um but I actually really like my
life um but it it it it wasn't that was
never really the goal I just tried to
avoid things I hated for the most part
and then when everything that I hated
was gone I kind of liked what was left
okay maybe one side note on on this I
know you are talking a lot about um you
you don't have to find your passion but
you can create your passion by doing
things U to get good at it uh to be then
passionate about it um but for for for
my opposite uh example from from before
um if if there are not two planes where
there is an one opposite maybe this is a
kind of a sphere or something where
there are several opposites um you have
to as you said maybe um eliminate one
after the other until you find the
opposite of it you
know so because I I opened the question
when uh with because I said um when you
don't know what you do it's a good thing
in general um oh it's a bad thing and
but if you if you what you don't want
yeah then it's a good thing and there's
maybe an opposite of it but maybe there
is not just one opposite maybe there are
a bunch of opposites if this is some
kind of a sphere you know um and where
how to find the the right opposite of
yeah I think you can cross out many
paths yes and so the way that I think
about this is um I think about it more
directionally then I think about it in
terms of the perfect pick and so I think
one of the big fallacies of
Entrepreneurship is that we're going to
pick right the first time and it's going
to be perfect and the reality is that
you don't have the context from which to
make the Judgment because you don't have
enough information because you haven't
done any of them and so it makes it's
it's a ridiculous hope to think that
you're going to pick right on the first
time it's really just like hoping you
win the lottery like of course like of
course you have no idea you've never
done it right and so um I think about it
in in the in the most basic terms it's
like okay do I like Words more do I like
numbers more it's like oh I like numbers
more cool well I can just cross out all
the stuff that has to do with words now
of the numbers careers what are all the
industries that are promly numbers or
career paths within those okay well
there's data analyst there's media
buying there's conversion optimization
like these are all things that are very
metric driven okay well which of these
well cro stuff is is a little bit
marketing and numbers okay well I don't
really like marketing stuff okay what
about finance and numbers okay I kind of
like that okay cool then you can start
and then all of a sudden you just you
just cut out huge tranches now at some
point you take the jump and you're like
well I'm just going to jump into here
and what ends up happening is that you
learn a ton of skills in that first
career path or first jump or first
business whatever it is but here's the
part that I think people mess up is is
that they think that if if you spend two
years they're like man I spent two years
doing this job or career or business
that I didn't like and they think that
somehow wasted when really all you did
was gain more information and I I tell I
mean a lot of people know the story from
Steve Jobs he took a class in
calligraphy right which made absolutely
no sense it's which is just writing like
how you write whatever handwriting and
years later when he came out with the uh
Mac it was the reason they had fonts was
because he took a class in calligraphy
years earlier and so if you follow the
quote perfect path you're not going to
have these little side quests that
create kind of the nuance and the depth
of your understanding and the different
perspectives that you can take to a job
or a career or a a business and so for
me like I came into the gym world with a
space cyber and intelligence background
from military Consulting right so like
it had nothing to do with that but the
thing is is that I approached I learned
a lot of skills at that position that I
was able to apply to the gym and so I
was able to look at the gym business a
little bit differently than I think a
lot of other gym owners did and so so
that gave me an advantage and so it
wasn't that I wasted those two years it
was just part of the path and so I think
that a lot of people really hard on
themselves and think that you need to
have the perfect pick but life is long
and it's about acquiring the skills
along the way and even if something
isn't the perfect fit you learn more
about what you don't like you cut that
stuff out and you lean more towards the
stuff you do and that's it because the
only reason that you have this Rush is
because you think you need to get
somewhere but you don't you're going to
die everyone ends in the same
place uh may you give may you give you a
little bit of context um I started
computer science and started uh my
business as a freelancer it's a
classical pth uh it was obvious somehow
then I moved towards being an agency I
hired people and took over projects um
but when I asked myself uh where do I
want to be in five years the answer was
total different I want to help people to
grow somehow okay I couldn't really see
this by being an agency okay um at least
not in the way I wanted to be so I
pivoted recently I shut down my small
agency after two years okay currently
I'm helping five software Freelancers
okay some like people like me to Build a
Better Business throughout my learnings
I do this for free um your first book
inspired me a lot um but this I hope to
find out uh what my product or service
can be and also finally to find my goal
my business goal you know is this
roughly how you would approach it like
test measure I'm gonna pull two parts
two things from that real quick so one
and this isn't to make you feel bad
about the decision that you made but the
that you couldn't help people while
owning an agency I think was was wrong
um because you absolutely could have
made the lives of every person that
worked for you better and so it's really
just like how you choose to Chunk Up the
goal because like you can absolutely
make the five or 10 people that work for
you every day have amazing lives and you
can have a deep impact on 10 people's
life that can last forever right and
their families and their kids and so
forth so I just want to put that out
there just because you're not the only
person who thinks this who's thought
that thought now with regards to where
you're currently at um I would think
about you did different things with your
agency there were probably some things
that you weren't good at there probably
some things that you were great at I
would just get really specific on the
things that you were great at and then
if there if there's elements of
implementation around those things that
you can help them do some done with you
or done for you service around that then
do that in exchange for money you know
what I mean um and you can make the
content around that and don't be afraid
of like giving away the secrets it's
never the issue because you know a good
uh a good friend of mine Neil Patel if
you know who he is um he is NE patel.com
it's a they they serve Fortune 100
companies for SEO and so he gives away
all the secrets of doing SEO and I've
I've we've talked about it and he's like
oh I I give I give I literally have
tutorials and everything that we do he's
like but no one wants to do it so they
just hire us and so like everyone has
this fear that like you're gonna give
it's like it's a lot of work no one
wants to work and so if you can just
give people a shortcut even if you
explain all the Nuance of the entire
process people just trust you more and
then when they do come to you they're
coming with clear expectations because
it's like hey have you consumed my stuff
they're like yeah it's like that's what
we're going to do
cool great and so I think just get
hypers specific on the things that you
were really good at within your agency
and don't pretend to be good at things
that you
weren't because you're gonna have you're
going to be um tempted to do that
because some of the people might start
getting into the running into the
obstacles that you ran into and then
look for you for help and don't make
[__] up because that's where you get in
trouble so what that would then do is
say hey I don't know I struggle with
this too but I'll bring in people who I
knew did a really good job with this and
then we'll learn together and then can
you can document that stuff so I'll give
you an example when I had my gyms um I
wasn't very good at at at at keeping
customers now I mean like I wasn't
terrible at it but I would never have
said I was a churn specialist I wasn't
really good at like super all ltu but I
was so good at the marketing and sales
side and making the business profitable
overall but like I had probably industry
average turn now when I had gym launch
and I had access to thousands of gyms I
was like hey who here has super low turn
and has had low turn for six months and
so I had 20 guys out of a thousand who
raised their hands so the top top Point
2% came up and I was like okay so I
interviewed all of them and found out
what every single one of them did now
all of them had a list of a hundred
things that they were doing but they all
did five things so five things all of
them did and so then I took those five
things I standardized it and then I gave
it to 10 gyms that were s that were
sucking at churn and I said do these
five things and let's see if your churn
improves and then their churn improved
by a lot and then I gave it to another
10 gyms and their turn improved by a lot
and I was like okay now I can feel
confident and I can State the facts and
tell the truth that Say Hey I was not an
expert at this so I found the answers
out and this is what happened to the
gyms that we did it with use it if you
want and so I would just approach it
from that perspective and don't flaunt
or pretend like you know something you
don't wherever you got stuck but for you
you've got the software guys get hypers
specific on the stuff you're good at
help them with that stuff either in a
done with you or done for you model and
I think you'll be
fine yeah great input many thanks for
this uh and for your time Alex and I
consume really uh everything literally
you put out there uh all the time it's
always mind-blowing so really a big
thank you well thank you so much for
coming on I appreciate it have a good
one
Alex imagine someone you know achieves
every dream and hits every goal they
have years later they get old and die
two years later how much do you care
about as much as everyone else will if
you accomplish your goals and dreams do
it for you you know um I mean this has
kind of been my mood going into this
call today to be honest with you um so I
told I told Jason who's behind the
camera I was like you know it's going to
be a weird day on goals because I'm gon
be like what does it matter you know we
all we all end up six six feet below the
ground anyways but I think uh the
opposite side of that coin is um all of
the reasons that we tell ourselves why
we shouldn't go after big things are
completely irrelevant after we die and
the people's opinions that we're afraid
of they too die and and so if people
live on past us they don't think about
us and if people don't live on past us
they're dead anyways and so the idea
that we would spend our entire lives
catering to people who will never think
about us again feels like a damn shame
and so um I think the constant reminder
for me that I'm going to die and that I
will be forgotten and that the goals and
achievements that I have are irrelevant
help me go after bigger things because
it makes life worth living for me in the
meantime hey Alex how's it going is it a
thief it's a thief nice what's up man
how's it going good good good just
wanted to say that I'm really grateful
for being on this platform having the
opportunity to ask questions directly to
you and um once again if my energy is a
bit low like I live in Dubai so it's
like 2:30 a.m. in the morning in the
morning right now how can I help so yeah
so getting straight to the point um
often times in the past I've set
ambitious goals for myself you know like
big goals for
myself but to hit these goals I've burnt
myself out which resulted in me not
hitting my next set of goals sure and I
start going in this mindset of like hey
sometimes things that you love don't
always love you back okay and in your
personal opinion how do you balance
between like ambitious goal setting with
the risk of getting burnt out and what
strategies would you recommend for
maintaining motivation over a long
period of time for to help with that
yeah I think I think u i mean it's a
good question and it's it's a common one
um and so I see that as a common
struggle so it's not a it's not a bad
thing um just know that you're not alone
with
it you know I
was the reason you get burnt out is
because you're in a
rush like that's it like you're in a
rush because if you if you said I have
to achieve that goal by the the time I
die you wouldn't burn out right and so
it's only based on an arbitrary
expectation that you set for yourself so
like you are burning yourself out like
no one else is like you choosing to set
a
goal like if I said I need to be a
billionaire tomorrow I I I could work
around the clock and I probably wouldn't
be a billionaire tomorrow was it a bad
goal well yeah but it was really more
that it was a bad timeline more than
anything now the flip side is
people ask me well once you hit a
billion then what are like are you going
to are you going to retire you going to
do something it's like well no then
people ask that about 100 and I was like
and once I get to a billion it'll be 10
billion because it doesn't really matter
what the goal is it's just who I want to
become along the way and the work that I
want to do on a daily basis and so I
don't think you would burn out if you
said I will commit to doing these things
and independent of whether or not the
goal happens what I care about is
progress and so so if you said I need to
be a millionaire in 12 months well the
math says that only one out of every 200
people is a millionaire like in the OR
sorry makes a million dollars a year
excuse me um it's it's less than that
for millionaires um but also that takes
into account that many of those people
are
70 uh and so they've probably lived
longer than you right and so you know I
think in the US uh the top 1% income is
650,000 a year right now that's top 1%
right and so to set a goal that like I
will be in the top 1% in 12 months I
mean you can set that goal it also just
doesn't matter like that goal is
irrelevant like why not six months why
not six seconds it like it's it just
it's completely arbitrary like you make
it up and then you stress yourself out
and to to try and hit it right but if
you said what activities would make it
unreasonable that I don't make
progress and if you do those activities
on a long enough time Rison you will you
will hit your goal and surpass it but
the thing is is like real real is the
goal just like doesn't matter like the
goal is the activities that you do
because the work is the only thing that
matters in the long run like the work
you do like the work is the goal and
like if there's if there's one message
that I could I could [__] get out
there to everybody is that a large part
of My Success has been that every year I
get closer and closer to what my ideal
is which is that the work is the
goal like that's it it's not the work is
the goal so that the winning takes care
of itself it's not we go to practice and
then the score takes care of itself
because even by saying and the score
takes care of itself or and the goals
happen anyways we still make the goals
King but if you make the work King as in
your dedication to doing excellent work
whenever you do it because that's who
you are and who you choose to be and you
don't put out subpar stuff because you
would
know it it channels into a different a
different level of energy like I don't
burn out I don't think I ever will burn
out it's not like and like for everybody
who follows like I'm not a high energy
guy you know I mean like I'm like
there's some guys I see like that guy
just doesn't stop like I stop all the
time right but I'll endure because I
keep my commitments like it's probably
one of the only things I do is I keep my
commitments and
so if you if you dedicate yourself to
Excellence overall because that's an
ideal that matters to you that's an
ideal that matters to me it might not be
you but like whatever whatever your
ideal is then you can live every day of
your life in pursuit of that ideal
knowing that you will fall short of
perfection but still trying to make
progress towards it and so even if one
day you don't work because you're
[__] exhausted it's not like well I
might as well eat pizza because I didn't
work out today it's like no I'll have a
slice and I'll work out tomorrow and
then I'll do it again and this this you
know this month I I worked out 13 times
the next month I'm GNA try to work out
16 rather than saying oh I fell off my
workout routine this month I burned out
it's just progress right and so I think
about what are the activities that I
will commit to and you do have to have
some sort of realistic thing like you
have to you have to pay rent you have to
eat food you have to make some sort of
money of course but am I is it
reasonable that I'm making progress
because at the end of let's say this
year if you go from whatever you're
making to let's say it's I don't need to
know what it is but let's just say it's
a $100,000 a year and by the end of the
year you make $200,000 a year but you
met you set your goal at a million are
you a
failure maybe you chose to make yourself
a failure if you want to if you want to
be a failure you can choose you can
choose to make yourself a failure you
can also choose to make yourself a
success right and so because then if you
look at that like well if I keep doing
that for another year I might be at
400,000 and I had I had my neighbor uh
Jacob years ago he was 15 years old I
said what do you want to do he's like
dude I just want to make money that's
what he said I said if I could have you
sign a contract that you make no money
for the next 10 years but then you're a
millionaire guaranteed 10 years from now
would you sign it and he said yes and I
say cool you're not living your life
that
way and so a lot of people say they
would sign it but then they turn around
and then don't they they act like they
have to be a millionaire in 90 days and
then it takes them 10 years to realize
that it was never going to happen and
they had to slow and steady proc
progress it just looks like it's fast
from the outside because that's how
social media portrays it people don't
get popular until they get big but just
no one sees the early 10 years you know
what I mean and so all that to
say commit to the activities that you
will do and then look at the outputs of
those activities and as long as you're
making progress and you have a feedback
loop of how do I get better how do I get
better how do I get better you will win
on a long enough time
Horizon but the reality is like the win
the w you move it anyways like as soon
as you hit a million you'll set the goal
at two million it like it's irrelevant
it just doesn't matter but what will
matter is the type of person you come
along the way because that person can't
be taken from you they can take your
money they can't take who you
are got it got it thank you so much Alex
for the information itself you know like
um obviously a lot of people listen to
this listen to this as well right so all
my friends like whether it's Daniel bass
or even um Alex himself like I'm really
grateful for this opportunity right now
thank you so much oh you bet man
appreciate you thanks for coming
on Alex Maxwell how you doing owner of
Rosen Crown what's up yeah yeah it's my
agency I've started the agency like
about six years ago it's been a wild
ride cool what kind of agency uh we do
um SEO and website content marketing
cool for small business um typically
like contractors and homebuilt design
Like Home Services got it cool yeah yeah
um I know this is about goals so I'm
gonna I'm going to start it off with a
little quote you might have heard is a
dream written down with a date becomes a
goal sure a goal broken down into steps
becomes a plan and a plan backed by
consistent action becomes
reality so that's a big thing that I
live my life by is creating this sort of
a goal ladder
sure and my question for you is like how
do you track your goals do you do um you
know I I use the bullet Journal method I
don't know if you've heard of that
before but that's how I can like track
my progress for individual goals as well
as business
goals it's a great question and I think
that my answer will surprise you
um I don't I don't really track uh many
goals um I haven't really
goals down um much in a while I mean we
have company goals and things like that
but those usually get broken down by
department and when I had a smaller
business um I didn't I didn't really
write them down that much um and so I
would I applaud you you're probably
doing something much smarter than than I
did um but I will say that I spent I
spent an inordinate amount of my time
trying to figure out what the one thing
that I can do that will make all the
rest of the things not matter or be
irrelevant and so like if there's one
problem that that I can solve that makes
all the other problems go away I try and
focus on that and so like a few years
ago I was like man all these billionaire
you know overnight billion dollar
companies are getting spawned by people
building big personal Brands and so I
was like well then I'll just do that and
so here we are right and so I I thought
like I try and think of like what is the
one what is the one chess move I can
make that makes the rest of this stuff
irrelevant and so then I just ruthlessly
dedicate myself to doing activities that
I think that'll achieve that and then
just get better along the way yeah yeah
no I I feel you on that um what do you
if you don't mind me asking what do you
think because I've already I've been on
a couple podcasts talking about this and
I have an interesting like perspective
on it but like when AI chat gbt this
stuff kind of Hit the hit the ground
hard uh last year I kind of saw the
writing on the wall that agencies in
general are going to go through like a
massive consolidation and um I think
that in three years maybe five but I
maybe less than maybe like three years
like a college kid is going to have one
software that kind of does everything
and they'll be able to out compete most
agencies you know down in LA or up here
in Santa Barbara what do you think about
that I think that there's really only
two modes of humanity there's humans
plus
tools and tools basically as long as
humans compete against humans you're
fine because that college kid
is going to have the same access as you
will and so as long as we are competing
against other humans I'm not really that
concerned because they'll have tools
I'll have tools we'll both use tools to
our advantage like all humans have since
the dawn of time the moment that it's
humans against machines machines win and
so but once humans are against machines
to me that's kind of like doesn't really
matter we're gonna lose and so we just
hope for the best that they like us um
but I don't just be really real like I
don't spend a lot of time worrying about
it because what am I going to do about
it right there's nothing that like what
what is going to change about my
behavior nothing and so until that day
comes I will equip myself as I always
have trying to best prepare use the
tools that are available try and
leverage those things so we can get more
out of them than other people can try
and adopt technology faster than my
competitors do yeah but if there ever is
a you know a trump Car Technology that
comes out there well then that questions
the meaning of life overall and it's you
know humans against machines and you
know money doesn't matter and you know
it's guns and gasoline or who knows
right but like yeah I I just again I I
go all the way down there and then I'm
like well what am i g to do today I'm
probably gonna make content that I said
I was gonna make I'm gonna write the
book that I said I was gonna write I'm
gonna take these calls I'm make these
investment decisions and that's what I'm
gonna do so that I I don't I don't
stress about it I'll just put it that
way I don't stress about it I think it's
easy to spin yourself up because then
you get into this existential threat but
you'll probably do what you've always
done which is you'll adapt yeah yeah and
I I did adapt so what we started doing
last year which is funny because when I
read your book and I've been watching a
lot of your things you kind of hit the
nail on the head on what we did with
Rosen Crown which is we basically
positioned ourselves as like Consulting
agents like a Consulting agency and what
we do is we train an in-house individual
right to do everything that we do using
the software that we do and then we just
charge monly for that yeah put yourself
out of business I love it it's great
yeah yeah so that's basically my
solution but yeah that was pretty much
it man well awesome dude well thanks for
coming on I appreciate it you yeah have
a good one all right see you
brother
work plus big goals equals ambition lazy
plus big goals equals entitlement big
goals don't make you different big work
does you know it's funny because like a
lot of people it's funny I mean this is
this is obviously a whole day on goals
but a lot of people have big goals like
that doesn't really mean very much it's
just what what are you doing about it
and when I see somebody who has huge
goals and isn't doing anything about it
it's just like they feel like they
deserve a big life
like you don't get a big Life by just
wanting it like everyone wants it
everyone wants a six-pack everyone wants
a beautiful wife or a beautiful spouse
or whatever everyone wants a big
business but that doesn't change
anything like your desire changes
nothing and claiming and like I hate I
hate
hate the all the deservingness worthy
Mantra that is pedal by the internet
because they want to tickle people's
ears and make them feel good about
themselves like it does nothing and so
a lot of people I
mean I try and boil everything down to
behavior which is what are you going to
do
and basically Nothing Else Matters like
all the words that people use to
describe their emotions to describe X Y
and Z like it just doesn't matter until
you translate it into activity like what
are you going to change about your
behavior even when we're talking about
the AI thing earlier it's like well what
are you going to change about our
Behavior if we're not going to change
anything about Behavior then then
talking about it doesn't serve us right
and
so having big goals is fine but I would
just say like it's honestly it's fine it
just doesn't matter like like if someone
comes to me like the amount of times I I
I have conversations like this people
like I want to be a billionaire I want
to help a billion lives and I'm like
cool man that's awesome what are you
doing about it like it's just easy to
say I had a gym owner once who's like I
want to help 10 million people get fit
and I was like no you don't you have a
local gym you don't want to help 10
million if you did want to help 10
million people you would you would go
about completely differently like you
say that because people around you nod
their heads and you sound you feel good
when people say that's great that's why
you keep saying it because you get
reinforced by other people when you say
it not because you actually [__] want
to do that
because it just comes down to what
you're going to do and so all day
long all of that ladders up to activity
and so if you don't know how you spend
your time in terms of what you do then I
can promise you that you're not going to
get where you want to
go anyways the deservingness worthiness
Mantra just it just like manifestation I
just I hate all of it I just think it's
just it's complete gobbley gck it's just
it's make belief it just it's not it's
not a thing like I can stand here and
just wish for a mill it's literally
wishing it's just saying if you keep
wishing for it if you keep wishing for
it it'll come the univer like as though
the universe gives a [__] about you
right the universe is going to deal you
something because we have one itis we
think we're the center of it it's like
it doesn't matter but I actually think
that's really comforting because it
means that you can not be worthy at all
you can not be deserving you can be an
absolute [__] you can be a [__] with
three fingers and like looking like this
and can't speak English and it doesn't
matter because if you still do the stuff
that gets you what you want you still
get it and to me that is the ultimate
equalizer if more people find out about
your stuff more people will buy if you
make your offer better more people will
buy and so do those things the rest of
it leave leave the manifestation and the
worthiness and the deservingness and the
affirmations and the self-love and
whatever the [__] else leave that to
your competition and while you stomp on
their necks as you just move past them
because you're focusing on doing more
and doing better of what has worked in
the
past then you'll get on podcast and say
you know I just always dreamed this way
and I just W I'm just kidding um anyways
that's my little rant for that
moment hi Stephanie hey Alex so nice to
be with you here and what you just said
is the reason I follow you um love what
you do I love your podcast um and I I
love the fact that you're on LinkedIn
now your little tidbits of
information um I am probably not your
typical follower so I work in nonprofit
uh but I I do my entire job is around
helping business owners so I'm around
business owners and
entrepreneurs all the time and I do
dabble in um businesses myself in my
spare time um so my question is around
um it's more General so it's around um
just being a person who has always has
some goals um whether they're learning
so um just learning new things so
learning goals um fitness goals as well
as um growing businesses um not
specifically my own but helping um
friends and um others to grow their
businesses
and my my question is like around how um
I I'm pretty aggressive about um having
all those goals and like how do I not
alienate um the people around me and
keep like the quality of those
relationships when I'm like go go go and
people are telling me to slow down or
take it easy um yeah so that's that's my
first
question before I answer what do you
think I'm gonna
say uh leave those people
behind
yeah yeah the thing is is like um you
can't be like you can't be all things to
all people right like they have their
dream for what they want Stephanie to be
like to them and you have your dream of
what you want Stephanie to be like and
what you're coming up against is the
conflict between those two ideas and so
they want you to behave a certain way
and that behavior they're basically
demanding from you and when you don't
act that way they punish you verbally
they avoid you they they send messages
whatever it is right they passively
aggressively make comments whatever it
is and so like as you level
up people either come with you or they
fall off and so I mean I tend to be
binary when it comes to either someone
is helping me achieve basically helping
me become the person that I want to
become or they're hindering me and I
just don't have room in my life for
people who aren't helping me right and
so um I think it's really admirable that
you're helping a lot of businesses with
the nonprofit and the things that you're
doing um and you have these goals and
so often times people get a lot of
anxiety so I Define anxiety by having um
many many plans
but few priorities and so you have lots
of things that you want to do but you
don't know which one to do and that's
what creates anxiety right just like I'm
not sure which way to go right the equal
opposite of that is sadness where you
just don't know any path because you
don't see any option whatsoever and so
it's a very different feeling and so if
you feel that way it just means you need
to make an order you have to Force rank
say what is most important to me and
everything else comes second to that and
if you can't like you have have to make
that order for yourself because it gives
you Clarity and once you have Clarity
then you can make decisions around an
outcome like this is what I want and
when I say for me from an outcome
perspective I really think inputs and
outputs like you said you have a fitness
goal you have a learning goal you have a
business goal right I boil all of those
down to inputs and outputs the same
reason I started this thing with saying
like our way of doing goals is we say
what's the input what's the output and
so Fitness the input is probably going
to be like I need to go to the gym and
lift weights or do cardio whatever it is
right X days a week cool that's my input
whether I get in shape not there's I'm
not getting into like nutrition all that
stuff but like like that's that's that
input right my learning goal is that I
want to read three books now I would
boil that down probably another level
because a lot of people mentally
masturbate when they read and listen to
podcast but I say I want to be able to
take something actionable from this book
and I'm going to do something about it
and so from every book I want to do one
thing I'm gonna take one piece of action
or I until I take action I'm not going
to read another book and so I actually
don't read nearly as many books as
people think I do um because I just try
and take action on them because my
definition of learning is same condition
new behavior and so if I'm in the same
condition and I haven't changed my
behavior I haven't learned anything and
so this book is really just the same as
watching a movie if I don't change how I
act and so I would make sure that my my
inputs after reading the book have
changed so that I can demonstrate that I
have learned and when it comes down to
the the businesses I would make sure
that you boil things down also for them
you can use this Frame if you're kind of
Consulting helping I'm not sure how the
nonprofit Works um it's to like what are
the inputs and outputs of the business
because every business is just a
pipeline at its most at its most basic
form there's something that comes in and
there's and there's money that comes out
and so what is the input that has the
the highest uh return on our effort and
time and capital or money and so a lot
of times people don't even know what the
activities they do they make money on
accident and I can promise you they'll
make a hell lot more money if they do it
on
purpose and so it's like yeah you know
we they a lot of people just spray and
pray they do a lot of different things
but they don't actually know that 90% of
their sales come from one channel you're
like cool well what if we 10x that and
then forget everything else because we
make that a priority and so the the big
picture is that strategy is just a fancy
dork word for priorities it's all it is
so when somebody says like what's your
strategy just means what things are you
prioritizing over others and it's taking
the limited resources we have in time
and money and effort against unlimited
options because there's a there's
countless things we can do but there's
limited things that we should do and
that's strategy and so back to the
original point of like you've got people
who aren't encouraging you [__] them you
already know that right well I like what
you uh told one of the previous guys
where you said work is the goal so I
think for me that's what it is right I
just want to work um so yeah so I love
that I I wrote it down so Alex one of
these businesses I'm helping is a
gym um so what is your advice on like
right now let's say around like 70
members um smaller gym like what's your
um one piece of advice to like double it
and then go big honestly the the simple
answer is I wrote an entire book on how
to grow a gym so I would say like read
that book read that yeah I recently
started um following you so I you know I
haven't um read that so yeah just just
read that book like you'll have more
than one way to double the gym like it's
just the business has not changed it
hasn't changed in in 50 years um it's a
very simple business the thing that
makes it harder is people it's a very
service heavy business it's one of the
you know there's a handful of businesses
out there that are that the what you
make a profit on is the quality of the
service that you provide which basically
makes it a training and culture business
which is why it's so difficult to scale
relative compared to like a food
business like you can have low skilled
labor that doesn't have you know
tremendous skill and you can keep
opening locations and making sandwiches
but when you have like a massage thing
like it really comes down to the massuse
it come Downs to the trainers it comes
down like that's why hair salons
oftentimes like there's not a huge hair
salon chain why is that because it's so
dependent on the individual stylists
right and so that's what makes the
business easy to start with a single
location guy who really loves what he
does uh more difficult to scale because
it takes a lot of systems and operations
specifically around training and
recruiting okay but if they have 70
members they're in the same spot that
most gyms are at which they're probably
breaking even and the owners making
$30,000 a year take come and working 80
hours a week um they just need to
promote more and they have to fix their
pricing I'd bet that those 70 members
what what's the price I'm getting a
little tactical but what's the price
that they're charging um like around $30
a class for an hour right okay so it's a
class it's a class based thing yeah um
they they they have to make more money
per they have to make a lot more money
so they have to charge more add
additional Services um that add value
they have to be reaching out to every
customer on a on a bi-weekly Cadence to
check in with them just because they
pretend they care um like there's just
just read the
book read the book and do the things in
the book I will um thank you so much I
like I said I love what you do and I
also love to listen to Leila's stuff so
oh yeah she's way better people just
don't know you yeah thank you so much
for having me thank you Stephanie for
coming on I appreciate
it Kenny you're muted just
FYI thanks Alex employee entrepreneur
that's great
it's where I'm you're good for the
Hest too
far um so for a bit of context
here I've got achievements and like I've
achieved goals in other areas of my life
up to this point mostly academics and
Athletics um I'm realizing now a lot of
those goals were external not really set
by me um consciously or unconsciously
so in terms of setting my own goals now
um I mean everyone wants to dream bigger
that's already come up so in business
how do you balance the Continuum
between what if this could turn out way
better than you expected and be
realistic when you're formalizing your
goals well dude I honestly don't think
it matters either
way like I I genuinely that that's just
right off the bat like you I'm going to
rewind and give you a little Kudos
because I think you you you might need
to hear it but the fact that you had the
achievements in your career and you were
an athlete before this it actually gives
you a pretty big leg up on most people
because um a lot of times athletes are
accustomed to working for very long
periods of time without reward before
achieving a goal they're accustomed to
the idea of years upon years to develop
skills that that take Mastery business
is the same way and so if you can TR if
you can generalize that approach to
skill Mastery within Sports and how you
worked uh with within team and having a
coach if you can if you can apply that
same perspective to business you'll
Crush you'll do great you'll go way
ahead way faster than most people
because you've actually done a lot of
other work that people have to do later
ahead of time so I just don't want you
to feel like you're at a disadvantage or
anything like that because like a lot of
your backgrounds actually prepared you
really well for the entrepreneurial path
so just like point one you should know
that um in terms of realistic versus big
goals dude like you're you
don't it it's kind of like it's kind of
like a a take this way I mean it like a
little bit of a mental masturbation
exercise of like how big could this get
or like I just want to be realistic like
it just doesn't matter like rational
design I think is complete like a
complete farce like no one's like it's
kind of like Mike Tyson's thing of uh
you know everyone has a plan till they
get punched in the face and like the
market will definitely [__] hit you
in the face and so as much time as you
spend the day you get in the ring all of
it's going to change and so I would just
encourage you to not spend too much time
in this phase because it doesn't matter
it's complete make belief like I have
never made a business plan in my entire
life I just know like okay well this
costs this much I think I could charge
this much let me see if I can let people
know about it and if they want to buy it
that's it like that's bit like you just
sell something to someone and that means
you're in business like a lot of people
really over complicated it's like you
have a service you do something that
saves someone time or effort and you
charge them a premium on your time in
order to do it because you have some
skill that they don't or some time that
they don't or you have some sort of
product that you developed that I mean
developed sounds super fancy like it you
know it could be whatever it could be a
food thing it could be a workout thing
it doesn't matter right you develop a
product you know what it costs you buy a
little bit more in bulk so you save and
then you have a markup and you sell it
over time you develop a brand because
you make content around it that shows
why your thing is superior and whatever
lifestyle and things that you want to
associate your products with that other
people who want to associate themselves
with those values will also choose to
vote with their dollars by buying your
product that they say that these values
matter to them that's all it is and so
there's all this [__] that makes
business really complicated
but like the like for you it's like dude
just sell something it doesn't matter I
would actually rather you just make a
sale on anything just to show yourself
that you can just get through all the
first steps which is like get the LLC
set up get a payment processor set up
get the bank account set up and then
like go ask strangers for
money I'm dead
serious serious as cancer man like
that's all you have to do there's all
this [__] that's like between your ears
and you seem like a nice guy this is me
just like you know picking up whatever
I'm picking down like speculation like
no you see like dude you you will win if
you if you just if you if you stop
thinking about it I promise you like way
Dumber people who are worse with other
human beings than you have won in
business like you can do it you really
can like I'm just saying like just off
of just like the tiny interaction I have
with you I mean it did sales for a very
long time so like Split Second
interactions like decent decent judge of
initial character you'll be fine dude
just have you have you read the leads
book yeah yeah okay do the warm Outreach
section do the rule of 100 and either
just pick whether you want to sell your
time at some sort of service to solve
problems for people or you want to sell
a product that's it and if you don't
have Capital just start with a service
and you sell your own time that's it
that's all you got to do if you've read
the offers book make a really good
offer message 100 people that you know
you already have a thousand people you
know right now on your phone you can do
this
tomorrow you can set up your LLC bank
account and payment processor
today that's crazy I love how you yeah
you simplify everything
so everyone else complicates it it's
always been the simple everyone else
just [__] complicates it it's all it
is that's my goal for you just do those
things and don't care about whether the
goal is realistic or unrealistic do that
make money and then all of a sudden you
have a way better perspective on how
this works
because it's like right now okay let I'm
gonna give you an analogy because I
think it might be helpful so what sports
did you
play uh iy ice hockey okay so imagine
you've got like a like a 10-year-old kid
right and he's never skated before all
right and he's like you know I've got
these goals between you know um becoming
a a high school coach and and and going
pro and I'm just debating on you know
what I should really set my goal for my
ice hockey career you'd be like dude
[__] get on the
ice like you don't even know how to
skate yet what are we talking about
right like you'd probably be like this
is ridiculous and so it's the same it's
the same perspective right like I think
you're spending all this time on the
side of the ring and you just got to put
your skates on to get
in and then you're gonna get hit on your
first game be like [__] that
hurt wow I can't do what I thought
because like he's on the sideline trying
to come up with plays for how he's going
to play Ice Hockey and he's never even
he's never even been in a game
yet I promise you you'll win though if
you actually do this stuff you'll win
you'll be
fine yeah that that makes sense thank
you second
question you have these goals now and
you're in that first stage you're in
your lonely
chapter how do you create that external
accountability to to get to these goals
when really you're just by yourself dude
you know
external
accountability what's the thing you're
most afraid
of cool uh yeah losing my house okay you
don't want to lose your house
right right then don't lose your house I
don't think you need any more external
accountability like I didn't want to go
home a failure that's all it was like
that was my external accountability
every time I wanted to quit I was like I
can't go home a failure I'll never I I
will [__] hate myself for the rest of
my life I won't do it I can't do
it and so losing your house is probably
a very painful idea so you're working
right now the good news is that you only
have to work 2,000 hours a year there's
another 6,800 hours that you can you can
put towards that more of your time
you're not working so just use some of
those hours do the rule of 100 and then
make as soon as you make as much or more
than you currently make at your job do
it for six months save up save up a nut
all that extra cash don't spend any of
it put it in a bank account and then
feel you'll feel good about getting the
other the other 40 hours 50 hours a week
back because then you'll just make more
but you just got to make are you married
I'm married yeah yeah so just you just
got to set and I'm saying this to
Kenny's wife because you can play this
recording to her um you got to give
Kenny space for this like you have to
you got to let him do this and it's
going to be a short-term sacrifice but
longterm if he doesn't do this he's
going to resent that you never gave him
the the the space right because long
term if if if she doesn't support you
I'm not saying she does or doesn't I'm
just saying but like if she doesn't
support you longterm in taking this
season because this will be a season the
thing is the season might last six
months it might Last 5 Years and I know
that's a big ask but at the same time
she probably loves you because she wants
you to be happy and she wants you to
realize your fullest potential and if
you're unhappy in your current thing and
you feel unfulfilled and you have this
hole that you just can't [__] like
every day you get in bed and you're like
I hate what I'm doing or I don't want to
do this I think I can do more you have
these feelings and you're just sitting
there at night like you don't want that
but I promise you you don't have those
thoughts when you're [__] exhausted
because you worked a double every single
day because you did your job and then
you started working on your career now
again be more be more purposeful with
the time you're probably have less chill
time less Netflix and relaxing and
probably be more strategic and be like
okay let's make sure the hours we have
count let's do stuff or let's let's make
sure that I carve out this time but then
it's like that's it like I'm gonna spend
the rest of our time so that five years
from now we can do whatever we want
whenever we want and I'm just ask but
she's gonna make this bet with you right
does she have a career
she does yeah okay well then you have
even more safety now so you're fine as
long yeah dude you you can't lose if you
actually do
it if you actually do what I just said
you will be
fine apprciate that thanks much back
Kenny you got it man thanks for coming
on when I started going after bigger
goals I found it more useful to write
down what I was going to give up more
than what I was going to do and in
general the bigger the goal the bigger
the sacrifice so I actually think this
is is is a second frame that um is super
useful so one earlier on um I think
Peter referenced uh if you don't know
what you want to do figure out all the
stuff you don't want to do and cross all
those things out first another way of
thinking about this from a goal setting
perspective is like you need to do these
activities but right now you currently
spend every minute of your day not doing
what you need to be doing and so what I
mean by that is if you've been plateaued
in your business at the same level for
six months or 12 months or more and you
spend all of your time
working then you're doing the wrong
stuff and so it means that you can't add
more to your plate before you take away
and so I remember there was this time
when I had six locations and I was
planning to get to 10 and I realized
that what I was like what I needed to
give up because I needed more time in
order to do that and so I realized for
me I was going to give up uh the Ravens
I'm from Baltimore uh I know sad sad
loss recently um but I gave up watching
and following football because you know
there's obviously the watching football
but then all of the ancillary stuff
around it like the commentators and like
who's coming up this week and what are
the matchups and how are the other teams
doing and how are the players doing and
fantasy and all that stuff so I gave
that up and I gave up basically all the
social interactions that I had around
that with friends because a lot of them
that was like the main thing that we
interacted on um and I gave up uh
Netflix because I used to watch Netflix
now I watch Netflix now because I'm a
different season but during that season
of kind of grind time I gave that up too
and I remember making this video um I
just went Facebook live and no one gave
a [__] because I was just a kid who
owned a couple gyms um but I was like I
just realized that like I have to give
these things up that I love and it was
because I loved the thing that I wanted
more and so I think um rather than
trying because like right now a lot of
people maybe are taking notes or they're
like man there's some activities I need
to be doing you can't add them to a
plate that's full you have to clear
space like you have to clear space and
that mean and and usually when you clear
space it hurts
because it's stuff you like doing and
that's and that's natural it's normal
but the thing is it's it's a it's a
short-term pain for a long-term gain or
the alternative is you continue to
suffer the same long-term pain that you
are while having these short-term hits
of gain right you the short-term
pleasures of fantasy football of Netflix
of of whatever you know the show you
follow or whatever your hobby is right
we do these things
but we sacrifice the big thing that
matters most to us and I think that
that's what leaves a lot of people
feeling empty like if you if you look
back on the last month or or quarter or
a year and you think of all the hours
that you spent on these activities that
don't really ladder up to anything like
they don't help you get forward or make
progress towards the ultimate goal that
you have and when I say ultimate goal
for me it's still very much like the
person you want to become and the
ultimate potential you want to realize
if if those things haven't laded up to
that you probably don't even remember
most of it you probably couldn't even
tell me what shows you watched or or or
the games that that played and like did
it really matter right
and so again you might love football
maybe that's really important to you
whatever it is but like if you're not
willing to give those things up then
just be able to say I did not hit my
goal and realize my potential because of
the
Ravens and when you say like that it
makes you feel like a [__] or makes it
made me feel like a [__] and I was like
well I'm not GNA let the Ravens stop me
from you know realizing what I mean
they're a great team and I love you know
I love I love supporting and I like
having the you know the friends that I
can talk about it with but if I can't
talk to my friends about anything
besides the Ravens are are they really
my
friends and so I would you have to
eliminate before you can add and
sometimes it hurts and that's
okay hey is it Karen or Kuran it's Quran
kurran there we go nice to meet you I'm
a big fan of your and Lea's work and
like it is so exciting to be here and
it's bit shy to be in front of so many
people and um so yeah my question was
about uh goals so I'm more or less in
the same situation as the I think Danny
what's most his name uh employee
entrepreneur and Kenny I'm sorry Kenny
so I'm still trying to figure out my way
and so I have a lot of goals and I'm
very easily distracted yeah so what
would be your suggestion like if I don't
have any um sales or business skills but
I still I'm in the want prer phase and I
I want to Chase my goals so what would
be your best advice for that
yeah well there's there's kind of two
paths that you can are you employed
right now or no I'm currently unemployed
now okay so there's there's kind of two
paths that I would I would I would
consider strongly so one is that I would
try and work for a small business owner
and the reason I would say small
business owner rather than a big
business owner or a corporation is
because in a small business you're going
to get to touch all the different
aspects of business because there's just
not that many employees and you can
spend your extra time trying to learn
from the other people who do those
functions so every small business is
going to have some element of marketing
they're going to have some element of
sales they're going to have some element
of product or service or customer
support they're going to have all these
elements and so if you go there you can
go with the full intention to learn and
just get paid to do it which I think is
a wonderful way and I think a wildly
underutilized way for people who are
kind of like not sure what to do go work
for some businesses that you think you
might want to start later it's the best
way to learn like I quit my consulting
job I didn't start a gym immediately I
went and I I worked for minimum wage I
was a consultant I was you know like I I
made a I made a good living I was a
Vanderbilt's very good school and highly
ranked in the US and um I went from a a
prestigious consulting job White Collar
doing space arban intelligence uh to
mopping gym floors right but I did that
because I wanted I had no intention of
staying mopping gym floors I wanted to
learn the ropes I want to learn how it
worked and so I worked at the gym I was
there 16 hours a day I got there at 4:
when the when the the owner got there
and he would leave at 4: so he'd work 12
and then I would I would keep working
till the gym closed because I wanted to
I want to know what the trainers were
doing I wanted to know what the what the
the billing person was doing I wanted to
know how the sales worked I wanted to
know how the marketing worked and so
that's what I did and I honestly the way
I did is I emailed 40 different gym
owners because I wanted to get in the
gym business and only one of them got
back to me and he off he said I could
work for him and so I drove out and I
wor and I drove out there with my car
and packed up and that was all I had and
I started working for him the next day
for minimum wage right he called me his
Apprentice right and so so like there
are there are a lot of paths and if you
if you feel like you have absolutely
zero knowledge you'll probably learn a
lot faster just getting into a business
and getting a feel for it and getting
paid to do it so that's the good it's
like you'll get paid to do it just be
willing to take a pay cut that's the
thing is everyone has this big ego about
like what they should what they deserve
I'm worth this it's like no you're not
you're not right you're worth what the
Market's willing to pay and if the
Market's not willing to pay that then
you're worth less and that's fine as
long as you don't think that that's your
worth that's your worth in this season
which is you're getting paid to be a
student everyone else pays to be a
student you get paid to be student what
what a wonderful life right so I think
that's path one now path two is if you
had because if you had said I am an
employee I'm making you know I'm making
money now I would have said okay learn
as much as you can from the business
that you're in if you like that business
and then take all the excess cash and
invest it in courses skills and when I
say this stuff because a lot of people
are like what courses BL it's not about
that like there's so much free
information on the internet you can you
can immediately use that stuff and
deploy it but there's still costs of
learning and so what I mean by that is
like if you if you want to you you want
to start a school Community like there's
a cost right you you want to start a
website Shopify cost money like you want
to like all these things but the thing
is the cost of starting those things or
start the cost of running your first ads
it costs money but you learn and so you
take the cash that you have and you
deploy it against those things right and
if you're like [__] I really suck at ads
then sure maybe pay someone for tutoring
that's what I did I literally paid a guy
who was a media buyer one of these
agency owners and I just said hey how
much do I have to pay you an hour he
Tred to be 750 an hour I didn't have
that kind of money and so I was the best
[__] student in the world I sat there
I recorded everything I took all the
notes and I did everything he said and
within six weeks I could run ads like
him and so like you can learn this stuff
quick if you just take the notes and you
apply yourself and you're willing to
risk some money and bet on yourself but
tldr if you're unemployed right now and
you want to get into the business game
figure out what business you want to get
in at least generally go to a small
business I would say 10 employees or
less and then say I will I I'll hustle
I'll work everything and I'll commit two
years I'll give you 24 months of the
absolute best effort ever and I and I'll
eat dog [__] in terms of what um willing
to make if you're willing to make the
trade that and you don't even have to
say this explicitly like I didn't say
hey Sam I want to learn everything from
you I was just like I just want to I
just want to learn and most business
owners want people who want to learn of
course because they want you to get
better because if you're better then you
make them more money right and then take
your extra time be friendly to all the
other employees and most people take
them out to lunch have zoom call
meetings with them see if you can if you
can help them and then they'll help you
and they'll teach you what they do like
this is how I've learned everything just
nice to people I try and do a favor for
them then I ask them if they can show me
what they do it's all I've done just for
a very long
time okay so in a nut chill just get
tied basically yeah in the short term
just remember like it's not it's not a
loss though it's not like you you failed
as an entrepreneur this is just a step I
was an employee first too it's not it's
not like not like you're failing it's
just like you expand the time Horizon
and see that you have to develop these
skills and just think okay I have to
develop these skills that's the
principle that I have to accomplish how
many different ways can I do that if you
you don't have the means right now
because you have to like eat and pay
rent then go get employment at something
in the industry that you're interested
in ideally in a smaller business so that
you can learn from those people and get
paid to learn what a
deal yeah if you put it that way that
makes sense yeah I think people should
put it that way yeah don't worry about
your parents or your friends or what
they say it doesn't
matter yeah everyone thought I took dude
I was I was a white collar consultant
from Vanderbilt finished in three years
I had above Harvard's mid score in the
GMAT like had the credit and all my
friends were doing really fancy
consulting jobs looking way cooler than
me and then when they found out I was
going to become a trainer at a gym
mopping floors like oh poor you he Alex
you know tough tough time I'm guessing
are are you Indian or you have a you
have a ethnic background yeah I'm an
Indian right and so I'm sure your
parents are tough on you I'm
guessing I'm guessing of course they are
and and and good for them right they're
trying to raise a good kid I get it um
but they want you to win and so I'll say
this as long as you work your [__]
ass off on a long enough time Horizon
you will gain their respect
back they said they're just going to
measure you on this because it's all
they know they're just doing the best
they can with what they know but the
world's changed since they were kids and
since they were your age right and so
it's okay to like I know this is tough
man believe me the hardest decision I
ever made was disobeying my father
hardest decision I've ever made and
quitting my job right now I think you're
in the position like you can get a job
that's below your pay grade my dad
didn't tell anybody that I quit and
started working at a gym he didn't tell
any of his friends until I owned a bunch
then he was okay talking about it again
right otherwise his son was a failure
right then he was a failure and then
he's like oh my God I'm a failure right
and so it's like you just have to have a
longer time Horizon for your success
than they do and they're ju and like
don't resent them they're just doing the
best they can with what they know of
course they are if they love you which
I'm sure they do they're just doing the
best they can with what they know they
might not say it well but that's what
they're doing and so go work even if
it's below the pay grade with the full
intention of working your ass off and
learning everything like rip all the
knowledge from that
business specifically learn the most
about acquisition which is how they get
customers learn
that when you have that then you can go
start whatever service you want and
maybe you'll learn how they do whatever
their services you can start your
own got it that's a lot of valuable
advice thank you so much you man good
luck dude you'll be fine thanks long
time Rising long time to win man all
right Spencer Alex nice to see you how
are you excellent how are you what can I
do for you good uh I would love two
questions but I will be happy with one
um the the first one
is how do you determine priority actions
when you have no tangible evidence or
results for which to make priority
action decisions from okay for what so
context wise I I do Fitness I mean I'm a
coach I have been for eight years
transitioned online and my main focus is
in the morning I do my deep work I write
long style posts I create content okay
um my goal for the year is to get 750
pieces of video content out I'm just
chasing that number as fast as I can and
in the afternoon trying to reach out to
as many people as I can before Facebook
or Instagram block me from reaching
people okay um when there's no real
results like you know direct for me to
directly say you know making this many
reals or making this style of real
talking on this piece of content to X
number of clientele or X number of calls
whatever yeah I just don't know if I'm
just doing too many things and if it
would be better to focus on two of those
things yeah um so how long you been
doing how you doing 100 reach outs a day
uh just about I do I've been I've been
averaging about 75 so far this year so
which is short of a 100 um okay and
that's the very t i so you're month in
so you're month in of do it so did when
did you start you started in like
January 1 when did you middle of
December I've been doing reach outs for
quite some time I there reach outs are
always the shittiest one and the hardest
one because I
have I I believe very little Goodwill
with my audience outside of the content
that I create I think most of the
connections I have are not warm okay
that's fine I mean that's why it's
cold so like that's fine okay and then
from a Content perspective you're
putting out how many pieces of content a
day two sometimes four uh usually two or
three reals and one still type post and
so from all of that you've gotten zero
customers this whole I've
gotten three or four this year I believe
okay so in eight weeks you've gotten
four
customers sure yeah five five six weeks
okay so five or six weeks you've gotten
four customers so you're getting like a
customer every 10
days roughly um actually which you know
so four yeah so one every like yeah 10
10 12 days okay um dude I actually I
think you're you're fine man I think you
just got to get
better so like you're doing you're doing
the right activities you just have to go
through the better Loop like right now
you're like I'll bet you your opening
message is probably not as good as it
could be I'll bet you nurture in the
conversation of like how you're doing
the ACA like acknowledge what they're
saying compliment them ask them the next
question like that could use some work
in terms of how you're actually
nurturing them to like get them
interested and clarifying what problem
that you're trying to solve for them and
then getting them to a call that you can
sell them on I'm guessing that's more or
less how your funnel Works essentially
yeah I most of the reach outs don't lead
to to anything yeah and that's okay
that's I mean if you it's it's 1% like I
mean it's it's a very low like it's a
it's a volume game and so you're getting
a customer every 10 days like if we can
improve like the nice thing with
outbound that I love love about this is
that like you can you can double a
response rate you can triple a response
rate and all of a sudden every 10 days
becomes every three days just from that
one change and so right now do you have
do you have all the metrics of that
lined out I know we're getting taxed for
everybody who's listening but this is
how we break [__] down so in terms of I
get your inputs so you're putting two
pieces of content out a day and you're
doing your reach outs okay so do you
have uh like your your next like funel
metrics you have certain number of
responses so are you met reaching out to
people who are um like liking and
commenting on on uh on the post and
whatnot yes but it's always the same
people and lately my content has been
getting less and less engagement yeah
okay so I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna give you
a a small piece on this is I'd rather
you spend more time and make one good
piece of content okay just make it
good so now now you just got to make
seven a week just one a day just make
one good piece okay just make it better
because in the content game quality does
like it's kind of this this tough thing
where like you have to make a lot in
order to learn what people kind of like
um but if you make too much you spread
yourself too thin because it's just you
and so quality still
trumps quality trumps quantity but
quantity quality trumps trumps quality
on its own right you want to make lots
of good [__] but one good thing like one
good video will make you more money than
10 mediocre shitty videos um but you
only get good at making videos by doing
more and that's why it's kind of like a
a chicken egg issue um I do appreciate
that you're getting the Reps in but D
you're five or six weeks in so like I I
would I would not lose steam it probably
also is a little bit of an expectations
thing like if you're getting a customer
every your 10 days like it's not
terrible like it's not it's not terrible
like like all we got to do is tweak one
part and then becomes every five days
now you're now you're at more than one a
week sure five or six has been like
three years like that's since since I
since I drastically increased the volume
I've been coaching for several years and
making content online I would say the
consistency is more in the past year and
a bit but the volume the volume
yeah go ahead keep going um the the
volume particularly recently because um
I mean full transparency I just kind of
hit a mental low that I just I didn't
really want to be alive anymore I felt
like I was just do I was the I was the
success zombie that that we we talk
about that you just you want the things
but you don't do yeah you don't take any
of your own advice andt it was it was a
really cool place to be because I
haven't been more excited to create than
I have I think ever which fantastic so
the volume I mean I I back to Kenny's
example of playing hockey like I played
hockey growing up too and I had a
shooting cage and I took literally
50,000 shots yeah and and so that was
like people I hated when people told me
like man you shoot really well yeah yeah
I've I've done it 50,000 times and so
that's my goal with content is do double
the amount and get better yes so like
you're like dude you're on the path
you're just early I'm being dead serious
with you man like the fact that you've
already got you've got like in the last
whatever five or six weeks you've gotten
four customers like you're you're just
on like shot like 300 of your 50,000
like you'll get better I would just make
sure that keep split testing the opening
lines and the offer that you're actually
presenting people when you're getting on
the phone with them uh because that
those are going to be the biggest levers
you have opening message and the offer
are gonna be the biggest levers that you
have in outbound by by a long shot and
if people aren't responding I would say
give away more free [__] so on that
opening message see if you can just give
give [__] away because you need to get
some traction you need to get some
inflow like this is just me sensing just
from like what you're saying like I
would rather you have a full roster of
clients that you're helping quote for
free and then barely be able to take
people on and then start raising the
price of hey I can't I can't do this
anymore for free and then start raising
price on those people and asking them to
pay like I'd rather you just give away
more [__] up front so you can get more
people
interested does that make sense in terms
of lead magnets or in terms of working
with clients because it has been years
and so like I I have my bills paid with
my client roster cool okay well then
yeah one I mean to me one and the same
there like the lead mic can just be a a
shorten period of time I mean you've
been through the the the the leads book
I'm sure so on the lead magnet chapter
it's just about like how can we just
give away more [__] on the front end to
get people interested just keep giving
stuff away until you get more people
engaged and that'll that'll dramatically
change your funel metrics like if I had
one tldr for you like one thing to take
away from this like oh two one make a
little bit less content I'd rather you
just make it better right rather because
if you're doing the solo two to four
pieces a day is [__] tough and the
reach outs and the client roster like
that's a lot of work dude so I commend
you on the work ethic drop it to one and
then the second is put all the excess
time into into giving away cool [__] now
I would say instead of giving away like
free materials I don't think people are
going to care a ton about that in the
fitness space just speaking from my own
experience I think what they will care
about is free time and effort and
Consulting and so that's where you can
like walk some like hey I'll do free
kitchen walkthr you can FaceTime me
we'll walk through uh your kitchen I'll
tell you what you should be eating or
not eating hey we'll do a free grocery
guide next time you go grocery store
let's schedule the time FaceTime me I'll
walk you through the store what you need
to get when you need to avoid like just
get a little bit more creative on the
stuff you can give away on the front end
just give and dude if you spend an hour
with someone talking about their food or
talking about grocery shopping they be
like [__] this was so helpful and then
they're gonna there's gonna be this
pause where they're like well how can I
get more of this right and you're like
well it's funny you ask and then you can
and you say hey why don't we talk
tomorrow I know you're getting in in the
car we'll talk tomorrow I'll walk you
through it cool and then they will show
up and they're very likely to buy but
just frontload on the on the on the DM
because if you went through the cold
outbound chapter in leads the biggest
breakthrough we had was giving more [__]
away on on our outbound like giving
front-loading more stuff to give to get
people engaged especially if you're cold
you got to make it insanely good for
them to respond warm traffic they'll
just get on the phone because they trust
you but cold you got to make it worth
their time and you have like this long
to do
it yeah those are the two takeaways one
piece of content give way more [__] up
front thank you I I appreciate that
and funny funny little idios synr there
synchronicity synchronicity um you said
when you give so much that people just
naturally want to that's how I signed up
a client today I got to the end of the
call it was goingon to be a strategy
call and she's like well can you do that
yeah sure dude that is how marketing
works so so do that just give that away
but strategy calls a little bit of like
people use those as sales call so like I
might call it something different but
just say like hey I'm going to walk you
through an entire nutrition thing it's
absolutely free I do it because I want
to give back to the community and it
helps me know people and at the end of
that call if they don't like sign up for
you just say hey do you have any friends
who might be interested in something
like
this didn't do that today all good no
like dude you're you're on like shot 300
of 50,000 like you're fine dude but dude
you're five or six weeks in you still
already got four customers like you're
fine just from an expectation standpoint
like you're super
early thank you it it feel it feels
longer because I've been at it for like
for years but it's
but dude you w early in the consistency
aspect yeah you weren't though you know
what I mean I'm only I'm only I'm only
pushing on that because I don't want you
to beat yourself up for it like you were
you were in this industry but you
weren't playing the game right like now
you have now you have skills and you're
playing the game you're thinking inputs
you're thinking outputs you're thinking
funnel metrics you weren't doing that
two years ago no [__] way right
you're doing that now and now it's just
going to go up I promise you like we're
just going to keep tweaking these little
aspects of the funnel and you'll be good
like if you're doing one every 10 days
it takes a double to get one every five
days days two doubles in your every
other day like you're this you're this
close
dude I appreciate that yep appreciate
you man thanks for hopping
on the bigger the goals you set the
bigger the failures you get scars we
collect from the monsters we've slain
you know when you go after big [__] um
it just hurts more when you fall um and
the more public you are about what you
want to do the more people will jump on
the bandwagon because you know people
love heroes but they don't love anything
more than watching a hero fail and so
expect that if you start going after
your goals and you start achieving them
people will start looking at you
differently and secretly they will start
hoping that you fail because it will
make them feel better about the action
they have never taken and so um like I
mean I I've told the story before but uh
when I was sleeping on the gym floor
uh a lot of my clients were like oh good
for you you're pursuing your dream you
know all that stuff um but then when the
gym started to work and I started to
make money and I started to be able to
live on my own um and I had like
managers and all that stuff like people
like ah big man you know decided to come
in oh thanks for gracing us with your
own presence today you know um and it
was this moment where I realized that um
people believe in the American dream are
root for it until it comes true and then
you become the man and I don't really
know when that happens but my postulate
is that it happens when you pass them
you go from pursuing the dream as the
underdog to the man the moment you pass
their level and so
um some of the scars that you have
aren't even from failures but they're
from relationships that you thought you
had that you don't uh because you
realize that people weren't actually
rooting for you they were making
themselves feel feel better by pitying
you and you thought they were rooting
for you but if they were really rooting
for you they'd root for you even harder
when you win and it's really rare to
find those people and the more you win
the more you realize that
like people who uh you see as friends
and acquaintances actually see you as
the competition and so um I would just
say like if I if I could tell my my
younger self that I would have just
prepared myself more for that and just
said like it's okay to lose friends
because they weren't friends to begin
with and you didn't really lose friends
you expose the fact they were never
friends to begin
with and that being said everyone I hope
you enjoyed the second episode of one of
zero live um if you like this stuff drop
it in the comments uh it it tells it
gives us the signal that uh like we
should keep doing this if you guys hate
it like we won't do it anymore so
definitely tell us uh it just gives us
really valuable feedback um so that we
can uh just help you accomplish your
goals which hopefully if you got
anything from to day um as long as you
work uh you have achieved the goal and
you become a success the moment that you
decide you are and that took me a very
long time to figure out so when you do
the activities you are by definition
being the person
that does the activities which means you
are realizing every day the potential
that you want to have so lots of love
keeping awesome and I'll catch you guys
later
by